But it turns out that the brain's default state
is really more like a car idling in drive than a car in park.
Some of what we think we choose to do
is actually things that we have become programmed to do
when the brakes are released.
Have you ever joked that your brain was running on autopilot?
Guess what?
It probably was.
OK?
And the brain's autopilot is in a structure called the striatum.
So the striatum detects emotional and sensory motor conditions
and it knows to trigger whatever behavior you have done most often
in the past under those same conditions.
Do you know why I became a neuroscientist?
Because I wanted to learn what made me tick.
(Laughter)
Thank you, thank you.
I've been wanting to use that one in front of an audience for years.
(Applause)
So in graduate school, I studied genetic factors
that orchestrate wiring to the striatum during development.
And yes, that is my former license plate.
(Laughter)
And for the record, I don't recommend
any PhD student get a license plate with their thesis topic printed on it,
unless they're prepared for their experiments not to work
for the next two years.
(Laughter)
I eventually did figure it out.
So, my experiments were exploring how miswiring in the striatum
relates to compulsive behaviors.
Meaning, behaviors that are coerced
by uncomfortable urges you can't consciously resist.
So I was really excited when my mice developed
this compulsive behavior,
where they were rubbing their faces and they couldn't seem to stop,
even when they were wounding themselves.
OK, excited is the wrong word,
I actually felt terrible for them.
I thought that they had tics, evidence of striatal miswiring.
And they were compulsive,
but it turned out, on further testing,
that these mice showed an aversion to interacting
and getting to know other unfamiliar mice.
Which was unusual, it was unexpected.
The results implied that the striatum,
which, for sure, is involved in compulsive-spectrum disorders,
is also involved in human social connection and our ability to --
not human social connection, but our ability to connect.
So I delved deeper,
into a field called social neuroscience.
And that is a newer, interdisciplinary field,
and there I found reports that linked the striatum
not just to social anomalies in mice,
but also in people.
As it turns out, the social neurochemistry in the striatum
is linked to things you've probably already heard of.
Like oxytocin,
which is that hormone that makes cuddling feel all warm and fuzzy.
But it also implicates signaling at opioid receptors.
There are naturally occurring opioids in your brain
that are deeply linked to social processes.
Experiments with naloxone, which blocks opioid receptors,
show us just how essential this opioid-receptor signaling is
to social interaction.
When people are given naloxone -- it's an ingredient in Narcan,
that reverses opioid overdoses to save lives.
But when it's given to healthy people,
it actually interfered with their ability to feel connected
to people they already knew and cared about.
So, something about not having opioid-receptor binding
makes it difficult for us to feel the rewards of social interaction.
Now, for the interest of time,
I've necessarily gotten rid of some of the scientific details,
but briefly, here's where we're at.
The effects of social disconnection through opioid receptors,
the effects of addictive drugs
and the effects of abnormal neurotransmission
on involuntary movements and compulsive behaviors
all converge in the striatum.
And the striatum and opioid signaling in it
has been deeply linked with loneliness.
When we don't have enough signaling at opioid receptors,
we can feel alone in a room full of people we care about and love, who love us.
Social neuroscientists, like Dr. Cacioppo at the University of Chicago,
have discovered that loneliness is very dangerous.
And it predisposes people
to entire spectrums of physical and mental illnesses.
Think of it like this: when you're at your hungriest,
pretty much any food tastes amazing, right?
So similarly, loneliness creates a hunger in the brain
which neurochemically hypersensitizes our reward system.
And social isolation acts through receptors
for these naturally occurring opioids and other social neurotransmitters
to leave the striatum in a state
where its response to things that signal reward and pleasure
is completely, completely over the top.
And in this state of hypersensitivity,
our brains signal deep dissatisfaction.
We become restless, irritable and impulsive.
And that's pretty much when I want you to keep the bowl of Halloween chocolate
entirely across the room for me, because I will eat it all.
I will.
And that brings up another thing that makes social disconnection
so dangerous.
If we don't have the ability to connect socially,
we are so ravenous for our social neurochemistry to be rebalanced,
we're likely to seek relief from anywhere.
And if that anywhere is opioid painkillers or heroin,
it is going to be a heat-seeking missile for our social reward system.
Is it any wonder people in today's world are becoming addicted so easily?
Social isolation --
excuse me --
contributes to relapse.
Studies have shown that people who tend to avoid relapse
tend to be people who have broad, reciprocal social relationships
where they can be of service to each other,
where they can be helpful.
Being of service lets people connect.
So --
if we don't have the ability to authentically connect,
our society increasingly lacks this ability to authentically connect
and experience things that are transcendent and beyond ourselves.
We used to get this transcendence
from a feeling of belonging to our families and our communities.
But everywhere, communities are changing.
And social and economic disintegration is making this harder and harder.
I'm not the only person to point out
that the areas in the country most economically hard hit,
where people feel most desolate about their life's meaning,
are also the places
where there have been communities most ravaged by opioids.
Social isolation acts through the brain's reward system
to make this state of affairs literally painful.
So perhaps it's this pain, this loneliness,
this despondence
that's driving so many of us to connect with whatever we can.
Like food.
Like handheld electronics.
And for too many people, to drugs like heroin and fentanyl.
I know someone who overdosed, who was revived by Narcan,
and she was mostly angry that she wasn't simply allowed to die.
Imagine for a second how that feels, that state of hopelessness, OK?
But the striatum is also a source of hope.
Because the striatum gives us a clue of how to bring people back.
So, remember that the striatum is our autopilot,
running our behaviors on habit,
and it's possible to rewire, to reprogram that autopilot,
but it involves neuroplasticity.
So, neuroplasticity is the ability of brains
to reprogram themselves,
and rewire themselves, so we can learn new things.
And maybe you've heard the classic adage of plasticity:
neurons that fire together, wire together.
Right?
So we need to practice social connective behaviors
instead of compulsive behaviors, when we're lonely,
when we are cued to remember our drug.
We need neuronally firing repeated experiences
in order for the striatum to undergo that necessary neuroplasticity
that allows it to take that "go find heroin" autopilot offline.
And what the convergence of social neuroscience, addiction
and compulsive-spectrum disorders in the striatum suggests
is that it's not simply enough
to teach the striatum healthier responses to compulsive urges.
We need social impulses to replace drug-cued compulsive behaviors,
because we need to rebalance, neurochemically, our social reward system.
And unless that happens,
we're going to be left in a state of craving.
No matter what besides our drug we repeatedly practice doing.
I believe that the solution to the opioid crisis
is to explore how social and psychospiritual interventions
can act as neurotechnologies in circuits
that process social and drug-induced rewards.
One possibility is to create and study scalable tools
for people to connect with one another
over a mutual interest
in recovery through psychospiritual practices.
And as such, psychospiritual practice could involve anything
from people getting together as megafans of touring jam bands,
or parkour jams, featuring shared experiences of vulnerability
and personal growth,
or more conventional things, like recovery yoga meetups,
or meetings centered around more traditional conceptions
of spiritual experiences.
But whatever it is,
it needs to activate
all of the neurotransmitter systems in the striatum
that are involved in processing social connection.
Social media can't go deep enough for this.
Social media doesn't so much encourage us to share,
as it does to compare.
It's the difference between having superficial small talk with someone
and authentic, deeply connected conversation with eye contact.
And stigma also keeps us separate.
There's a lot of evidence that it keeps us sick.
And stigma often makes it safer for addicts to connect with other addicts.
But recovery groups centered around reestablishing social connections
could certainly be inclusive of people who are seeking recovery
for a range of mental health problems.
My point is, when we connect around what's broken,
we connect as human beings.
We heal ourselves from the compulsive self-destruction
that was our response to the pain of disconnection.
When we think of neuropsychiatric illnesses as a spectrum of phenomenon
that are part of what make us human,
then we remove the otherness of people who struggle with self-destruction.
We remove the stigma
between doctors and patients and caregivers.
We put the question of what it means to be normal versus sick
back on the spectrum of the human condition.
And it is on that spectrum where we can all connect
and seek healing together, for all of our struggles with humanness.
Thank you for letting me share.
(Applause)